en este vídeo vamos a comparar
diferentes números y tenemos por ejemplo
0.1 comparado con 0 punto 0 70 lo que
vamos a hacer es saber que el número es
más grande que cuál y para ello lo que
haremos es analizar cada una de las
posiciones de valor que tiene cada cifra
y con eso ver la diferencia entre ambos
números y saber cuál es más grande
empecemos aquí este uno se encuentra en
la posición de las décimas por lo que
colocaremos que exposición de décimas
y lo que nos representa es un 1 x un
décimo lo que significa un décimo
ahora con el siguiente número veamos en
el siguiente número tenemos 0 en las
posiciones de las décimas pero tenemos
un 7 en la posición de las centésimas
centésimas o lo que nos representa de
sus 7 x
un centésimo
que es igual a 7 centésimos
si nosotros quisiéramos pensar este
undécimo en términos de centésimos lo
que haremos es multiplicar por 10 tanto
el numerador como el denominador para
que de esta manera no se altere nuestro
número y multiplicaríamos
1 por 10 10 10 por 10 100
undécimo es igual a 10 centésimos y
ahora podemos hacer muy clara esta
comparación si nosotros quisiéramos
hacer más grande este 7 nos moveríamos
en el mundo de los centésimos y serías 7
centésimos luego 8 centésimos 9
centésimos y con ello llegaríamos
después de sumar varias veces hasta los
10 centésimos es por eso que podemos
decir que un décimo es mayor que 7
centésimos o 10 centésimos son más
grandes que 7 centésimos y nuestro
símbolo de mayor que menor que se abrirá
hacia el número más grande que en este
caso es 10 centésimos vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo tenemos cero puntos 0 0 9 3
comparado con 0.01 tomemos otro color y
veamos en este número tenemos nada en
los décimos nada en los centésimos y
tenemos un 9 en la posición de las
milésimas
mientras tendremos un 3 en la posición
de las 10 milésimas
vámonos número por número en este caso
el 9 en la posición de las milésimas nos
representa un 9 x
milésima o lo que es lo mismo nueve
milésimas
mientras el número 3 está en el lugar de
las 10 milésimas y eso nos representa un
3 x
diezmilésimos
o lo que es lo mismo 3
es milésimos
si nosotros queremos convertir este 9 en
términos de diezmilésimos para poder
hacer la suma multiplicaremos tanto el
numerador como el denominador por 10 y
así tendremos 9 por 10 90000 por 10
10.000
y ahora si podemos hacer la suma tenemos
diezmilésimos
vamos a analizar el punto 01 qué
significa este punto 0 1 y aquí tenemos
que está en la posición de las
centésimas este 1 está en la posición de
las centésimas
o lo que es lo mismo uno por un
centésimo
que es igual a un centésimo
vamos a bajarlo para poder trabajar toda
la misma altura
ahora sí este un centésimo lo queremos
ver en términos de diezmilésimos vamos a
multiplicar por 100 tanto el numerador
como el denominador y esto para mantener
nuestra fracción equivalente podemos así
tener el mismo lenguaje y compararlos de
una manera mucho más sencilla
así es que multipliquemos 1%
100% 10.000
ahora si tenemos 100 diezmilésimos
comparados con 93 diezmilésimos cuál es
mayor pues el 100 diezmilésimos así es
que colocaremos nuestro símbolo de mayor
que menor que con la apertura hacia el
número más grande vamos bien hagamos un
par de ejercicios más ahora tenemos seis
representado en dos valores posicionales
distintos una vez en las décimas y una
vez en la centésimas cuál será más
grande empezaremos con el seis en las
décimas este seis se encuentra en las
décimas
o lo que nos representa un 6 x un décimo
que es igual a
es decimos muy bien
y vámonos con el otro color en esta
posición que damos que no hay nada en
décimas pero si este 6 está en la
centésimas
o lo que es lo mismo seis por un
centésimo
o seis centésimas
se dan cuenta cómo es exactamente el
mismo número sin embargo el valor cambia
dado la posición es por eso que llamamos
valores posicional es en este caso para
que pensemos el 6 decimos en términos de
centésimos multiplicaremos por 10 tanto
el numerador como el denominador y ahora
si es evidente que 60 centésimos es
enorme comparado con los 6 centésimas
que tenemos aquí
así es que colocaremos nuestro símbolo
de mayor que menor que con la apertura
hacia el número más grande
el último ejercicio y con esto
terminamos vamos a cambiar los colores
una vez más tenemos un caso muy similar
un 3 en la posición de las décimas y un
6 en la posición de las centésimas a
pesar que son diferentes números si
tenemos la claridad de que son distintos
valores posicionales de cualquier manera
vamos a hacer paso por paso para que
esto sea más evidente tenemos es de 3 en
la posición de las décimas así es que
tenemos tres por un décimo o lo que es
lo mismo tres décimos y si analizamos
este otro número tenemos el seis en la
posición de las centésimas o lo que es
lo mismo seis por un centésimo
si hacemos la multiplicación tenemos 6
centésimas
vamos a pensar este 3 decimos en
cuestiones de centésimas así es que
multiplicaremos numerador por 10 y el
denominador por 10
con ello tendremos ahora así más clara
nuestra comparación 30 centésimos es
mucho mayor que 6 centésimos y con ello
colocaremos entonces el símbolo de mayor
que menor que apuntando el lado abierto
hacia nuestro número más grande